I TRIED TO POINT THIS OUT THAT
HE SHOULD ADD THAT TO HIS DIET.
GREG: THAT IS CNN, FOLKS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
STOP.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I AM
OUTRAGED OUT.
TWEETS HERE, SEE WORDS THERE,
EVEN THE FLYING NUN GOT
INVOLVED.
[LAUGHTER]
I AM NOT KIDDING.
THE FLYING NUN IS THROWING THE C
WORD AROUND LIKE A NASTY
FRISBEE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO AMERICA.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO PEOPLE?
WHAT DID WE LEARN FROM THIS WEEK
ABOUT RAGE?
IT USED TO BE WHAT COST YOU YOUR
JOB IS A THING YOU DID BEHIND A
TREE AT THE COMPANY PICNIC.
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU ARE LAUGHING, YOU KNOW.
NO, NOW IT IS TWITTER, THE ONE
STOP CAREER LIQUIDATOR.
ALL IT TAKES IS ONE IDIOTIC
STATEMENT AND YOU DISAPPEAR
FASTER THAN A TWINKIE IN MICHAEL
MOORE'S LAP.
[LAUGHTER]
WHERE WOULD I BE WITHOUT MICHAEL
MOORE'S LAP?
I'D BE OUT OF JOKES.
AS THE ONLINE WORLD ENCOURAGES
MOB ACTION OVER FORGIVENESS
COMPANIES NOW NEED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES SO TWITTER HAS BECOME
A GLOBAL HUMAN RESOURCES.
AS THE PROPOSITION COMBINES MORE
FORCE TO DECIDE WHO STAYS AND
WHO GOES.
IT'S NOT FORGET ON TWITTER THE
WORLDS BATHROOM WALL, ALL
INTERRUPTIONS ARE PERMANENT AND
YOU ARE BRANDED.
YOU ARE BRANDED FOR LIFE.
YOU CAN'T BLAME TWITTER AND IT
DID NOT WRITE THAT TWEET,
ROSANNE, AND EVERY COMPANY HAS
RIGHT TO FIRE YOU OVER WORDS.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH WITHOUT
CONSENSUS ONLY EXISTS AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT.
FOR THIS WEEK THE OFFENSES WERE
NOT ONLY ON TWITTER OR BY
ROSANNE BUT TWO WOMEN SAID THAT
THINGS THAT ONE APOLOGIZED AND
LOST HER JOB, ONE APOLOGIZED AND
KEPT HER JOB.
THAT IS LIFE BUT LET'S BE CLEAR,
I ACCEPT ALL APOLOGIES.
IF YOU ARE SORRY I ACCEPTED.
I SAY THIS KNOWING THAT THIS
FAVOR MAY NEVER BE RETURNED TO
ME AND THERE ARE ORGANIZATIONS
TO DEVOTED TO CATCHING ME
SCREWUP.
IT IS TRUE.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I WILL FORGIVE ALL EVEN IF
THEY WOULD AND ME WITH GLEE.
LET'S DO THE SIMPLE EXERCISE.
IF I SAID WHAT SAMANTHA BE SAID
ABOUT THE DAUGHTER OF A
PRESIDENT HOW LONG I LAST?
I WOULD BE MARCHED INTO A THAT
OF TRUCK DRIVERS BACK SWEAT.
[CROWD BOOS]
I WOULD HAVE REQUESTED THAT
ACTUALLY.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT AS RIGHT EXPERIENCE BOYCOTT
LEFTIES GET AWARDS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE EVENTS
BUT THE TRIBE.
ONE TRIBE IS LESS FORGIVING THAN
THE OTHER.
I'M WILLING TO FORGIVE WONDERS
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S
RECIPROCITY OVER THERE AT THE
LEFT.
WHY IS THAT CUSTOMER YOU THINK
THEY ARE STUPID, THEY THANK YOU
ARE EVIL.
MEANING A CONSERVATIVE BELIEVES
A CONCERT OF LIBERAL IS
MISTAKEN, A LIBERAL BELIEVES A
CONSERVATIVE IS IMMORAL.
IT'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
IT'S BEEN EXCUSE BECAUSE YOU ARE
BAD.
IF SOMEONE IS EVIL YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING TO THEM, YOU CAN MIMIC
THEIR BEHEADING, YOU CAN CALL
HIM ON A C WORD FOR POSTING A
PICTURE OF A CHILD, YOU CAN WISH
DEATH ON AMERICANS REFUND.
WE ALL KNEW SAMANTHA WOULD
SURVIVE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
STORY.
SHE WAS SAFE.
THE CONTEMPORARY LANDSCAPE, THE
LIBERAL JOKERS HEART IS ALWAYS
IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
AFTER ALL, IVANKA TRUMP HAD IT
COMING.
SHE'S A MOM AND HER DAD IS EVIL
BUT THAT IS LOGIC.
IF ONE GROUP SEES YOU AS EVIL
IF ONE GROUP SEES YOU AS EVIL,
WHAT STOPS OTHERS ARE MOVING
BEYOND THE SPEECH?
REMEMBER THE ANTI- SAW THE
WEATHER UNDERGROUND, THE UNIT
BOMBER?
ALL MAJOR VIOLENCE, THE KIND OF
THE MASS KILLING VARIETY, DID
NOT START WITH I DISAGREE WITH
YOU.
IT WAS YOU ARE EVIL AND WE MUST
STOP YOU.
TRUMP HAS TRIGGERED ANGRY
PEOPLE, KATHY GRIFFIN, THE
DECAPITATE ARE IN CHIEF, SHE
STILL SEES HERSELF AS THE VICTIM
AND THERE IS TOM ARNOLD, CHELSEA
HANDLER, WHAT HAPPENED, JIMMY
KIMMEL, SARAH SILVERMAN WHO
WANTED A MILITARY COUP, ROBERT
TO FIND HUNCH THE PRESIDENT,
ALEC BALDWIN, JIM CARREY AND NOW
EVEN THE FLYING NUN.
[LAUGHTER]
IT BREAKS MY HEART.
I LOVED SALLY FIELDS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO BROKEN BY
TRUMP THEY NO LONGER SEE YOU AS
HUMAN THAT IS A PROBLEM.
I GUESS AFTER THE OBAMA ERA ALL
THIS LOSING IS UNKNOWN
TERRITORIES WERE WATCHING A
NATIONAL TANTRUM FOR SPOILED
BRATS.
WHAT DO YOU DO POLITICAL
ADVERSARIES ONE YOU RUINED BUT
YOU WANT THEM HEALTHY ENOUGH SO
YOU CAN DEBATE THEM?
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY DEMANDING
SCALPS, SHOULD WE DO THE SAME AS
A MUTUAL ASSURED CAREER
DESTRUCTION?
IS THAT THE ONLY WAY TO GET
EVERYONE TO STOP THE OUTRAGE
CRUSADE?
I DON'T KNOW BUT THAT IS NOT ME
AND IT SHOULD NOT BE YOU,
EITHER.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
IS WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE HAS MORE GOOD-HUMORED THAN
THE ICE CREAM MAN, TV WRITER AND
PRODUCER ROB LONG.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DON'T TALK TO HIM WITHOUT A
NURSE BECAUSE HE'LL PUT YOU IN
STITCHES.
DAVID ANGELO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE DRINKS HER OWN TEARS TO STAY
HYDRATED.
NATURAL REVIEW REPORTER,
CAPTAINS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND HE STOLE HIS PINKY RING FROM
SATURN, FORMER WWE STAR AND MY
MASSIVE SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
ROB, YOU ARE A BIG-TIME
HOLLYWOOD PRODUCER COME CHEERS,
THAT WAS THAT OTHER SHOW --
>> RECENT CANCELLATION.
I'VE BEEN THERE.
GREG: YOU WERE CANCELED BUT YOU
DID NOTHING RAISINS.
>> NO, WE JUST AND NOT OLDER
AUDIENCE.
BY THE WAY, GREAT CONTEMPORARY
REFERENCE WITH THE FLYING NUN.
FANTASTIC.
IF YOU ARE UNDER 80 YEARS OLD
AND YOU HAVE THE SHOW ON 50
YEARS OLD, HALF A CENTURY AGO.
GREG: DID YOU SEE HER TWEETS?
>> I DID.
GREG: SHE IS THE 28 TO PILE ON
IVANKA TRUMP WHICH EVERYONE WAS
TRYING TO OUTGROWS EACH OTHER,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY TRY TO DO.
THEY TRY TO PYLON OR A QUICK
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
IT'S SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
ROSANNE STREET AND SAMANTHA B'S
STATEMENT ARE DIFFERENT BUT WHAT
DO YOU DO?
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TROUBLE WITH
YOUR ADVERTISERS AND YOU CAN'T
IGNORE THAT AND IT'S A HALF A
BILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS THAT SHE
TORCHED AND THE REAL QUESTION IS
WHY DID THEY NOT TAKE HER PHONE
AWAY BECAUSE THAT IS EVERY OTHER
STAR ON THE TV HAD TO GO THROUGH
SOMETHING CALLED THE PHYSICAL
AND YOU HAVE TO GET INSURED AND
FROM COMPLETION BOND AND IF YOU
CAN'T BE INSURED YOU WILL NOT
GET THE JOB.
GREG: WHAT IMPRESSED ME WAS THAT
ROSANNE GOT IN TROUBLE AND I
LIKED THE IDEA OF THE SHOW
ITSELF BUT IT WAS SLOPPY BUT I
LIKE THE FACT THAT THEY
PRESENTED A CIVIL DISCOURSE THAT
WAS MISSING SO I WAS HOPEFUL AND
THE PERSON PRESENTS THE CIVIL
DISCOURSE GOES AHEAD AND SHOOTS
IT IN THE HEAD.
SHE CREATES THE THING THAT WAS
MAYBE THE WORLD WILL CHANGE AND
THEN SHE TREATS THIS AND IT ALL
GOES AWAY.
>> IT'S DEPRESSING.
IT WAS NICE, I ADMIT IT WAS NICE
TO SEE A CHARACTER ON TV WHO WAS
NOT AN OPEN COMMUNIST.
[LAUGHTER]
WE HAD FUN FOR A FEW MONTHS.
BUT NOW WE GO BACK TO IT.
IT'S TOUGH NOW AND THEY'LL PUT
THE FREEZE ON THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS, I FEEL LIKE.
IT WILL BE -- MY AGENT TOLD ME
MAKE SURE THE PILOT IS OUT
BEFORE YOU PUT YOUR HEAD IN THE
OVEN.
THE ADVICE I GOT.
GREG: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
SPIRIT YEAH, THAT CONVERSATION
HAPPENED.
GREG: DO YOU BUY THE EXCUSE
BECAUSE THE REASON WHY I BRING
IT UP IS EVERYONE KNOWS SOMEBODY
WHO'S HAD AN EXPERIENCE WITH
AMBIEN BUT THAT WAS ROSANNE'S
EXCUSE?
KAT: I DO NOT BUY THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT AMBIEN MAKES
YOU RACIST.
I THINK THAT WHAT SHE SAID WAS
UNACCEPTABLE AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY SHE WOULD THINK
IT WAS WORTH IT.
THE BEST THING ABOUT TWITTER IS
NOT ONLY DO NOT YOU PAID FOR
YOUR TWEETS BUT YOU CAN GET
FIRED FOR THEM.
GREG: THERE IS NO UPSIDE.
KAT: I DON'T KNOW WHY ANY OF US
ARE ON THIS APP WHATSOEVER.
I SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO DOES
ABSOLUTELY, LITERALLY NOTHING
ELSE BUT I DON'T KNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S SAD.
GREG: WE'RE ALL VERY SAD.
>> I THINK TWITTER IS
INTERESTING.
BEFORE TWITTER I WAS STRUGGLING
IN OBSCURITY AND AFTER TWITTER
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE KNOW
THAT I'M STRUGGLING.
[LAUGHTER]
KAT: IT'S GOOD FOR THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG:
GREG: WHAT DO YOU -- SAVE YOUR
JOKES FOR THE SHOW.
TYRUS, OKAY, WHAT ABOUT SAMANTHA
BEE?
THE AMAZING THING IS NO ONE
EXPECTED HER TO BE FIRED BECAUSE
IT WAS PLANNED AND I THINK IT
WAS PLANNED.
THE AUDIENCE LOVED IT AND THEY
ALL CHEERED WHEN SHE DID IT.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A DIFFERENT.
TYRUS: IT'S DIFFERENT.
I THINK -- IT WAS RECORDED,
EDITED, WATCH BEFORE AND THEY
WERE EXCITED ABOUT IT.
IT WAS A PREMEDITATED HIT AND
WHEN THEY DID WHAT THEY DID
BECAUSE THERE WAS BACKLASH NOT
BECAUSE IT WAS WRITING TO DO
THAT IT WAS WRONG TO CALL
SOMEONE THAT ESPECIALLY OF HER
HOLDING A CHILD WHICH I THINK IS
[BLEEP] THAT THE SPONSORS WERE
LIKE NO, WERE NOT GOOD WITH
THAT.
IT'S OKAY, I GUESS, BECAUSE SHE
GOT -- HERE'S WHERE IT GETS
WEIRD.
SHE GOT AWAY WITH THAT BECAUSE
SHE WAS A WOMAN BECAUSE IF I
WOULD HAVE SAID THAT ON THE SHOW
AND YOU HAD LET IT RUN YOU
WOULD'VE BEEN -- AND GREG YOU
WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE, I'M SORRY,
TYRUS, I CAN'T TALK TO YOU
ANYMORE.
GREG: THAT'S TRUE.
I WOULD DROP YOU LIKE A HOT
BRITO.
TYRUS: HELLO, SORRY, THEN YOU
WOULD BASH ME AND SHOW BAD
VIDEOS OF ME AND SAY HOW HE
NEVER LIKED ME AND YOU ARE
SCARED TO COME TO WORK I WAS A
BULLY.
GREG: YOU KNOW ME SO WELL.
TYRUS: YOU WOULD'VE BURIED ME.
GREG: SO QUICKLY.
TYRUS: IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE IF A MAN WOULD HAVE SAID
THAT ON THE SAME TIME SHOW HE
WOULD NOT BE AROUND ANYMORE.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
THE OTHER THING THAT I THINK IS
ON US AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS FUNNY WAS THE PRESIDENT WAS
UPSET ABOUT THE APOLOGIES.
THAT HAD ME LAUGHING.
MR. PRESIDENT, BRO, YOU DON'T
APOLOGIZE WHEN YOUR STAFFER SAYS
THAT ABOUT JOHN MCCAIN, NO, WE
DON'T APOLOGIZE OVER HERE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND THE NEW
TRUMP PUBLICANS WE DON'T
APOLOGIZE FOR NOTHING.
FOR HIM TO BE LIKE WHY ARE WE --
I WAS LIKE, ON MAN, YOU GOT TO
BE MISSING AND JOKING AROUND --
THE RIGHT DO NOT APOLOGIZE THEY
JUST KEEP GOING.
RUIN EACH OTHER'S LIVES IN AND
LOOK TO US TO DO THE SAME THING
AND WERE LIKE NO, WE ARE DOING
THAT STUFF.
GREG: I SEE THIS OUTRAGEOUS
CYCLE MOVING SO FAST THAT YOU
HAVE AN ERROR THAT'S DRIVEN BY
EMOTION, STUPIDITY AND THAT GETS
THE INSTANT OUTRAGE IN THE
COMPANY THEY WORK FOR SAYS HOLY
CRAP, THIS PLACE IS GOING UP IN
SMOKE BECAUSE THEY ARE WATCHING
TWITTER AND THEN THEY DON'T WANT
PERMANENT DAMAGE SO YOU'RE GONE.
TYRUS: ONE OF THE THINGS IS
ABETTED BY WAS THE MAINSTREAM
COVERAGE WAS ROSANNE WAS SHE WAS
THE VOICE OF THE RED AND HER
CHARACTER WAS.
PEOPLE JUST LIKE ME, I LOVED
CONAN THE
CONAN BHE
CONAN BARBARIAN.
HE'S HAPPEN TO BE COOL AND I
DIDN'T KNOW HIM.
I LIKE THAT GUY AND AMERICA LIKE
THE CHARACTER.
THEY LIKE THE FAMILY, NOT THE
PERSON WHO MADE THE RECENT
STATEMENT, THAT IS WHO THEY ARE
HER PART.